>>> WELCOME TO "HANNITY" THIS
FRIDAY NIGHT.
TONIGHT FULL MIDTERM COVERAGE
WITH ONLY 32 DAYS UNTIL THE
MIDTERMS STRAIGHT AHEAD.
TEXAS SENATOR TED CRUZ WILL BE
WITH US.
ALSO ARIZONA HAD A SENATE
CANDIDATE DEBATE LAST NIGHT.
BLAKE MASTERS PERFORMED
PARTICULARLY WELL AGAINST MARK
KELLY AND DESTROYED HIS
DEMOCRATIC OPPONENT.
WE WILL BRING YOU THE HIGHLIGHTS
OF THAT DEBATE.
>>> WE BEGIN WITH PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN.
HIS CASUAL WARNING ABOUT A
LOOMING NUCLEAR HOLOCAUST.
LAST NIGHT DURING A CLOSED-DOOR
FUNDRAISER WITH OTHER TOP
DEMOCRATS BIDEN CLAIMED THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE,
QUOTE, FACED THE PROSPECT OF
ARMAGEDDON SINCE KENNEDY AND THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS.
NOW BECAUSE ACCORDING TO JOE
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS NOT JOKING
WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT THE USE OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS OR BIOLOGICAL
WEAPONS OR CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
APPARENTLY THERE IS NOTHING JOE
WILL DO ABOUT IT, BUT HE DID DO
THIS.
THE ADMINISTRATION ARE BUYING
$300 MILLION WORTH OF ANTI-
RADIATION DRUGS.
THAT'S NOT REASSURING.
THAT IS JOE'S BIG PLAN IN THE
EVENT THAT "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT" USES NUCLEAR WEAPONS?
THAT'S IT?
NO ONE IN THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
ARTICULATED A STRATEGY TO DETER
LATIMER POTENT OR WORK ON ANY
DIPLOMATIC SOLUTION ON THE WAR
IN UKRAINE HAS NO END IN SIGHT.
IT APPEARS THAT JOE BIDEN IS
ONLY BRACING FOR THE WORST.
GET READY, IT IS LINE UP AND GET
YOUR RADIATION BILLS.
TONIGHT WE HAVE A SERIOUS
QUESTION.
HOW WORRIED SHOULD AMERICANS BE.
OBAMA ONCE REPORTEDLY WARNED
AMERICANS NOT TO UNDERESTIMATE
JOE BIDEN'S ABILITY TO BLEEPED
THINGS UP.
FORMER OBAMA DEFENSE SECRETARY
ROBERT GATES, REMEMBER HE WROTE
THAT BIDEN HAD BEEN WRONG ON
EVERY SIGEL FOREIGN POLICY
DECISION IN THE LAST FOR
DECADES?
NOW HERE WE ARE FACING A DIRE
NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS.
BUT TODAY JOE WAS NOT INTERESTED
IN ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
ARMAGEDDON OR THE FORTHCOMING
ARMAGEDDON AS HE CALLS IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU THINK ARMAGEDDON IS
COMING?
>> RUN, JOEY, RUN.
HE DID A REALLY GOOD JOB THERE.
ANYWAY, JOE WASN'T RUNNING TOO
AN IMPORTANT NATIONAL SECURITY
MEETING.
HE WAS IN A RUSH TO GET TO
DELAWARE AS USUAL FOR REST AND
RELAXATION.
HE HAS LESS THAN ONE SCHEDULED
EVENT PER DAY AS PRESIDENT.
THIS LESS THAN 20 FOR HOURS
AFTER WARNING ABOUT THE END OF
TIME.
JOE IS TAKING THE WEEKEND OFF
AGAIN.
WE DON'T HAVE A LIST OF WHO IT
IS THAT HE SEES IN DELAWARE
EVERY WEEKEND.
APPARENTLY THE SECRET SERVICE
LOSES ALL OF THAT INFORMATION.
I WOULD ASSUME THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES AND RECORDS
ADMINISTRATION WOULD PROBABLY
WANT THAT INFORMATION.
BEFORE MAKING IT OFF TO
WILMINGTON, THE PRESIDENT MADE A
QUICK STOP IN MARYLAND TO
INTRODUCE HIS SELF-PROCLAIMED
TWO WORD PLAN TO SAVE OUR
ECONOMY.
TWO WORDS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET ME START OFF WITH TWO
WORDS.
MADE IN AMERICA.
THAT'S NOT HYPERBOLE.
I AM NOT JOKING ABOUT THAT, AS
YOU KNOW.
SINA COME ON, MAN.
TWO WORDS.
MADE, ONE, INN, TWO, AMERICA,
THREE.
JUST LIKE THE THREE LETTER WORD
JOBS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JOHN'S LAST-MINUTE ECONOMIC
PLAN DOES NOTHING TO TACKLE THE
NUMBER ONE JOB FACING THE MIDDLE
CLASS AND IT HAPPENS TO BE AS
BARACK SAYS A THREE LETTER WORD.
JOBS.
>> JOBS.
I COUNTED FOR.
MAYBE MY CALCULATOR IS OFF.
THIS COUNTRY IS NOT IN GOOD
HANDS.
WE ARE NOW WORSE OFF BY EVERY
SINGLE METRIC SINCE BIDEN TOOK
OFF HIS.
CAN YOU ANYTHING THAT JOE HAS
DONE TO MAKE THE LIVES OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BETTER?
HE PROMISED TO BUILD OUR ECONOMY
FROM THE BOTTOM UP.
NOW THE POOR, THE MIDDLE CLASS,
AMERICA IS ON FIXED INCOMES.
THEY ARE ALL GETTING SHAFTED BY
RECORD INFLATION, RISING GAS
PRICES.
HE PROMISED TO RESTORE UNITY IN
THE COUNTRY.
THEN HE GOES OUT TO PHILADELPHIA
DEHUMANIZING ALL REPUBLICANS AND
CALLING THEM A THREAT TO OUR
COUNTRY.
HE PROMISED TO RESTORE AMERICA
STANDING AROUND THE WORLD.
THAT'S A JOKE.
NOW ACCORDING TO HIM WE ARE
FACING THE BIGGEST THREAT OF
NUCLEAR ARMAGEDDON SINCE THE
HEIGHT OF THE COLD WAR AND THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS.
AND STILL BIDEN IS DESPERATELY
ATTEMPTING TO SALVAGE A DEAL
WITH IRAN THAT WOULD ALL BUT ARM
THEM WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND
GIVE THEM BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THERE IS A DECREPIT BRAIN DEAD
PRESIDENT IN THE OVAL OFFICE WHO
IS NOW SURROUNDED BY OTHER
INCOMPETENT IDIOTS.
AS A RESULT, THIS COUNTRY OF
OURS IS NOW ON THE VERGE OF
IMPLODING BY EVERY METRIC ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER.
THERE IS ONLY ONE WAY TO TURN
THE CORNER.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS GOT TO BE
CHECKED.
IN 32 DATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE IN A REPUBLICAN HOUSE AND
SENATE FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
32 DAYS.
IT'S ALL IN YOUR HANDS.
I AM DEPUTIZING ALL OF YOU.
TAKE IT AS SOMETHING THAT IS OF
GREAT IMPORTANCE.
YOU WANT TO BE SAFER.
IF YOU WANT MORE STABILITY IN
YOUR TOWNS AND CITIES.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO PAY $5 A
GALLON FOR GASOLINE